et bien messieurs j'ai le plaisir de
vous annoncer la visite de bourvil ça
nous fait très plaisir de vous voir là
bonjour
sipa ce pathogène bonjour je quand on
aime le cinéma on aime bovine à
aujourd'hui
et puis à une époque quand on est même
music hall on aimait bourvil mais
malheureusement on va plus se voir music
hall au wharf on est bien content de
voir la télévision
qu'est ce que vous faites en ce moment
je sais ce que vous venez de faire parce
que j'ai le plaisir de vous interviewez
l'émission d'euros s'il ya quelques
semaines je viens de faire un film avec
avec ça fait accompagné de robert hirsch
et monique terme s et s'appelle le crack
et le film est en train de se monter on
va le voir mon très prochainement être
un film en couleur une grande fresque
consacrée aux cyclistes 1900 c'est un
lieu où on l'appelle indics c'est un
grand fumeur
on verra le verdict du public mais je
crois qu'on peut dire que alex joffé à
mi-temps brami en train tout eu toute
une équipe toute une troupe parce que
vous avez combien de coureurs cyclistes
sur les routes de france
on était tous en tout 80 je ne sais pas
il y avait 3 3 équipes à la gauloise les
touristes et une équipe italienne et on
vous a fabriqué des vélos 1900 avec du
matériel
dieu merci beaucoup plus léger et nous
avons aussi des voitures 19 cents
c'était assez haut en couleur je pense
que enfin je préfère ne rien dire parce
que le dernier film de vous que l'on ait
vu à paris c'est les arnault oui avec
adamo avec adamo de transfuges du
music-hall justement passé au cinéma ou
ville et les films que vous préparez je
vais sans de faire un film avec jean
pierre mocky qui avait fait avec moi
hawass y est allé c'est un jeune metteur
en scène que que j'aime beaucoup je
pense qu'il aime beaucoup de talent et
puis là il a un humour
corrosif ou bien à 8 ensuite je ferai un
film avec gérard oury qui a fait comme
vous savez le corniaud grignan dans la
drôme
les deux plus grands succès du cinéma
depuis quelques années et j'aurai la
joie de jouer avec belmondo
vous n'avez jamais je vais belmondo
c'est une fois c'est une question à
poser à la voa vous commandez un
candidat candidat
j'ai joué une fois je me dis partie de
ces toutefois vous poser la question non
non non
la question n'est pas prévu non mais
vous venez tout de même de parler
d'autre chose mais que voulez vous c'est
la vie à tous la question est posée aux
deux messieurs alors ça leur fait un
avantage là tous les deux et bien si
vous voulez je vais leur poser des
questions
vous avez la retrouver au pinceau non
pas ça de la vue vous avez parlé d'autre
chose et un instant que nous allons
retrouver à vôtre monsieur p cariou je
commence par vous vous connaissez le nom
du metteur en scène des grandes gueules
monsieur collard le titre du film
interprété par bourvil et réalisé par
rené clair oui monsieur p curio le titre
des deux films ou bourvil et michèle
morgan pour partenaire oui oui monsieur
collard le metteur scène d'un drôle de
paroissien
monsieur piccirillo
le titre du film qui outre bourvil
réunissait sean connery richard burton
john wayne et arletty oui monsieur
collard le titre du seul film ou bourvil
eu louis jouvet pour partenaire
entendons-nous d'ailleurs il faut il
faut être prêt si vous étiez dans le
film tous les bus mais vous n'aurez pas
de sel nous n'avions pas de sun nah le
titre du seul film ou dans la
distribution et bourvil et louis jouvet
monsieur p curieux vous pouvez prendre
cette question
non alors monsieur p kalou prenait des
cinq premières questions
le metteur en scène des grandes gueules
robert enrico oui
le titre du film interprété par bourvil
et réalisé par un éclair le trou le
larousse est malheureusement monsieur
klaus avait même trouvé abattu dans sa
tombe bien pour et bien c'est brûlant
c'est tout leur demande alors le titre
des deux films bourvil et michèle morgan
pour partenaire fort que la wii et de
mire le miroir à deux faces c'est sa
fortune à d'alex joffé miroir à deux
faces d'andré cayatte le metteur en
scène la drôle de paroissien mocky jean
pierre mocky et le titre du film où l'on
pouvait voir bourvil sean connery
richard burton john wayne et arletty
jour le plus long
le jour le plus long bien sûr
[Musique]